nobody ever thinks it's our kid that
something's gonna happen to but I worry
that if he was coming home by himself
and somebody saw him by himself and he
was vulnerable I I don't know what could
happen several years ago when my son was
9 he asked if he could ride the subway
by himself and my husband and I let him
I wrote a column about it and two days
later I was on The Today Show MSNBC Fox
News NPR I had obviously struck a nerve
what did you think about your mom
letting you have this opportunity I was
like finally nobody could believe that a
decent mother would let her son go
underground by himself and let him find
his own way helped me it was letting him
have a little independence that he was
ready for thousands of blog posts later
I wrote the book free range kids I have
a television show now called world's
worst mom that's me so I started a
business call me if you're really
nervous and I will send your kids
outside while I lock you in doors it's
as simple as that
and I've done it several times and it
just works it works because reality
breaks through this gigantic fear that's
been foisted down parents throats that
they have to be worried about their kids
every single second
Leah and rusty are from New Mexico
they're not native New Yorkers but
they've been living in a very lovely
safe leafy part of New York City for the
last year or so with their two children
and they remember their own childhood
freedoms really fondly I grew up on
about three and a half acres so we spent
much of our days just riding the horses
we were always outside all day long my
mom and say go do whatever you're gonna
do don't hurt yourself and we'll see you
later
I was hectic my mom this morning I don't
remember her ever coming looking for us
contrast that with what is your son
allowed to do now at 12 I gotta say he's
probably I mean he's on a much tighter
leash than than I was I feel like my
family's my responsibility then it's
difficult to put your kids safety at
risk well do you think you'd be putting
his safety at risk cuz I'm I'm not a fan
of putting kids at risk I truly am NOT I
mean I'm actually a nervous mom yeah I
worry that if somebody saw him by
himself and he was vulnerable okay I
don't know what could happen they've
been walking for a year they're in New
York City yeah sure nice turtle legs
look and you're not that far from a
grocery and it's still light out I don't
think it's raining all right could we
ask them if their game would you begin
there we can ask Leon the kids and see
if it's something that they want to do
and it's something you're game for I'll
be nervous but if if they're comfortable
with it you'll feel comfortable crossing
the street yes using the street right
yes okay that's fine
one of the reasons I think we're
particularly worried about cars today is
because we're with our kids all the time
and when you're with your kids you look
out for the cars so it looks like your
kids aren't paying any attention
whatsoever if you want your kids to be
really safe you can't do everything for
them you're not building a competent
child had you not specifically asked
about it and had they not brought it up
I don't think we would have probably
thought them do this anytime in the next
probably year I think I see felt a
little bit out of control and you know
just hope that that they were okay
you know they're proud of you
yep you're proud of them yeah
for what for letting us code being brave
enough to let us go
and that's toast yeah you proposed a
toast please to letting our kids venture
outside and spread their leaves the
sense at the end that like look at my
kids instead of like oh my kids the the
fear gets replaced by this joy and the
kids are like my parents believed in me
it's emotional
you